tres grandes compromisos hizo el
presidente Joe biden aquí en la cop 27
la primera es la creación del plan de
acción sobre el metano con el que se
espera que Estados Unidos reduzca en un
87% sus emisiones de este gas de aquí a
2030 otro de los anuncios es duplicar el
respaldo que da al fondo de adaptación
para llegar a 100 millones el doble de
lo que prometió en la Cope 26 en Glasgow
y otro de los anuncios es dedicar 150
millones para acelerar el plan de fondo
de emergencia para adaptación y
resiliencia y dentro de ellos se cuentan
500 millones para ayudar a Egipto a una
transición energética algo que hace en
Alianza con la Unión Europea y Alemania
el presidente biden no habló sin embargo
de una de las promesas esperadas que era
reducir las emisiones de los
contratistas federales en Estados Unidos
por otra parte
defendió la ley para la reducción de
inflación con la que dedicó 170 mil
millones de dólares para combatir el
cambio climático sin embargo los
activistas estadounidenses dicen que
claramente sí es el plan más grande en
la historia pero porque nunca ha habido
otro y que este moto representa tan solo
el 4% de lo que se destina al
presupuesto de defensa
el problema principal de la ley para la
reducción de inflación es que no hace
nada para enfrentar nuestros problemas
de combustibles fósiles en el mundo solo
destina dinero para la energía renovable
pero también afianza el interés por los
combustibles fósiles le da a las
compañías de combustibles fósiles las
posibilidades para ser más nuevos
arrendamientos para explorar gas y
petróleo y Esa es la dirección opuesta
de donde Necesitamos ir
lo que le pedimos a Estados Unidos es
que crea una especie de mecanismo de
financiación que pueda hacerle frente a
los daños y las pérdidas y comienza a
financiar las clases de reparación que
son necesarias por parte de los grandes
contaminadores de Estados Unidos y que
han afectado a las comunidades que poco
hicieron para causar el problema